تختلف من دوله الى دوله كان يقول انه شكل
السياسي نظام السياسي مبني على ثلاثه
جغرافيا طبيعه الارض والمناخ والعادات
والتقليد لو تحضر ليبيا بين السنوسي وسيف
الاسلام القذافي تجد الكفته راجحي لسيف
الاسلام القذافي لانه هناك في حنين لهذا
في العراق لو تاتي بين الملكيه العراقيه
او نظام صدام حسين الحنين لنظام صدام حسين
اكبر في تونس لما تتكلم على النظام الملكي
اللي كان قبل الحبيب بورقيبه او نظام ابن
علي ابو رقيبه الحنين عند التوانسه
الاغلبيه هو الحنين لنظام ابن علي لانه
ابن علي 2010 كان الدوله الاولى في
التنميه لا تستطيع في العالم العربي ان
تقول هناك وصفه معينه لنظام الحكم يتشكل
بلا شك انه يعني تونس في حنين كبير لعوده
ابن علي لانه نظامك مستقل الله يرحمه كان
مستقر لانه واضح انه في العالم العربي
يبحثون عن
الامن والتنميه بغض النظر عن النظام
السياسي